well uh another one who's qualified
definitely for the quarterfinals this
time is uh magnus carlsen
and magnus what happened in this final
game against hikaru
um david's saying maybe you were
trolling him a little bit about with
that opening uh
no it's uh just another way
there have been so many draws uh uh
with this uh queen queen uh d
e4 d4 queen e6 in the berlin so
i thought i'd show people that there are
other ways to
repeat as well um uh
yeah so i yeah now i just wanted to to
have a little bit of fun there
all right um well we have seen hikaru
today i mean i don't know how many
minutes he's all together played
today it's not many to say at least are
you i know i know we know you love to
to play out all games magnus are you a
little bit annoyed to see some players
go for these super quick draws all the
time
no it's okay uh it was
uh was a little bit annoying when wesley
played for a draw against me like it was
so annoying that i
i made a mistake at some point and
almost and almost lost
uh but i guess apart from that
uh 15 rounds is a lot so i understand
that some people want to
want to take a break uh sometimes
as for myself i i mean i
i've massively enjoyed playing here so i
just want to
yeah i just want to play and play and
have some fun
and i mean magnus what about that score
you're
you're ending up on 10 and a half out of
15 i mean that's a record no doubt in
the meltwater champions chess store
how do you feel about your score oh it's
obviously really really good um
today was
probably a day of some wasted chances
against uh
arunian and especially duboff
so it could have been even better today
but i think overall
um yeah i am obviously
thrilled about the score and i think uh
overall it was
uh pretty fair as well um uh
when con considering the positions that
i had
and magnus this is the fourth melt water
championship
event the fourth time you've topped the
preliminary groups well
unless and each wins i think and uh yeah
are you going to do anything differently
to the last three events uh
be worthless so
i do really hope that i uh
i mean not that i don't want to buff to
qualify
but i really really want to play
somebody else
i can understand that right now i guess
it's uh jana pognaci
in eighth place that would be super cool
magnus wouldn't it
yeah he's i he that would mean
twice against two buff and and once
against napomnishi i think in the first
round
or no no he was in the second round it
was yeah with
giri uh in the first first event
uh yeah certainly would be it would be
would be interesting yeah
all right well magnus we have been
talking about so much your
your chest form so far in the melted
water champions chess tour
how are you feeling about your intuition
how is it feeling now so far in this
tournament
i feel like it's i feel like it's okay
uh
i think i i i i think i just need to
change
gears a little bit when it comes to
the quarterfinals because so far it's
been
uh fairly sort of uh just
play by by air and uh as i said earlier
i think i i need to
to up my game a little bit for for the
um
uh for the knockouts and so that's what
i will
we'll be striving to do but in terms of
uh in terms of warm-up this was as good
as it
uh as good as it gets and final question
magnus uh you promised the return
of the vest will you bring it back in
the knockout stages
yes i will uh i will bring it if not
tomorrow then
then the day after definitely looking
forward to it so ryan is good luck in
the court fans tomorrow
thank you thanks for joining